marketing for the now the marketing for
the now marketing for the now marketing
for the now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a singular important question
[Music]
are you ready gary
what do you think
happy tuesday
are you ready for marketing for the now
gary i'm always ready for everything you
are always ready
we've got a pretty cool lineup of
creators and brands today uh and our
question is what's the latest for
creators and communities so please join
the conversation
marketing for the now
we're going to kick things off with
stacy taffet she's the vp of marketing
for frito-lay
stacy has been at pepsico for 13 years
and is an absolute rock star in her role
she's running the largest brands in the
snack portfolio some of my favorites
including leis and doritos cheetos
ruffles and fritos are there any other
snacks is my question
and one other very important thing gary
that you should know is that she happens
to be a jets fan i love her welcome
stacy
it's so painful
stace you telling me
how are things
yeah things are good how are you gary
it's good to be here it's great to see
you thank you for being on
so look obviously the brands that you're
sitting on top of are so iconic have so
much
popular culture references brands that
show up in super bowls and
you know are in every aisle of every c
store or supermarket so i guess
you know
knowing that the products also do an
incredible job skewing young versus
other brands
not that i don't see tons of people in
their 80s eating chips
but you know
i think this is a great way to kick it
off what is what is your
point of view on where the opportunity
is for creators
and and what's the impact of communities
on brands like the ones that you work on
yeah i mean i think you know we started
even just talking about being a sports
fan i think you know fandom and creating
fandom around brands is really what
we're we're setting out to do now and a
big part of fandom is creating
communities both in the digital world
and and in you know in the real world as
well um and stoking that fandom and
nurturing that fandom and so you know
when i thought about the question about
creators and building communities there
were sort of three three principles that
came to mind and i can share a little
bit about doritos and cheetos because
those tend to be the brands that skew
younger and um we have some good
examples uh for but the the first one
for me around this idea of creating
community is you know the way we the way
we do marketing has evolved right from
the legacy way where it was about
distributing the consumer experience
like we'll tell you how you should
engage with your brands right to now a
world where we're participating we're
encouraging people to participate
in that experience and the experience of
our brand and we can build communities
around those experiences so um you know
a couple a couple examples that
that we've recently done that i think
illustrate this one you know one of the
the business problems we uh we were
trying to solve was um you know keeping
reminding everybody on the doritos brand
about how awesome and timeless nacho
cheese is right
when you taste nacho cheese doritos i
don't know if you have in a while um
you're going to be reminded that it's
the world's most perfect food and so in
the old world we would have just you
know told you that we might you know
remind you how great it is that that
nacho cheese doritos exist
but we what we did just this past summer
was we decided to create a job called
the nacho cheese flavor confirmer
which is inviting someone to taste nacho
cheese it's a real job we're paying them
to taste nacho cheese doritos every day
and tell us that it's still awesome
and the way that we hired for that is we
invited people on tik tok to do an
interview it was a duet
and tell us why they deserve the job so
much so we really built this community
around the love of this brand and this
product um and it was a huge success and
our flavor confirmer is being paid uh
every day uh that he tastes a nacho
cheese dorito
um and then was it a uh was it a um
was it a challenging
decision on who got the head nod was it
there's some real love there's a real
love and some real creativity and the
creators came out in full force and uh
in showing us how much they they love
the brand so what about what about stacy
the human being like what creators
yeah influencers
or communities reddit 4chan discords
uh uh or even like a text group of like
13 friends or moms or professionals or
linkedin groups or facebook groups like
what about you the human outside of like
the uni you know the hat you put on when
you're running these big global brands
what strikes you what gets you
what catches your attention
just in general yeah like if you if i
asked you what's fun about this another
10-minute hangout yeah and i'm trying to
bring as much value i'm reading the
comments from frosty reel and
grandmaster uv and william mcconnell and
i'm i'm listening but i'm also thinking
what will bring the most value and
sometimes when you take
a very successful operator in marketing
and you spin it from like hey this is
how you're thinking about as you should
be
doritos or frito but like hey take a
quick step back and be retrospective
like what have you noticed has worked on
you what brand did you buy because of a
creator or an influencer or
what's your go-to community like is
there a facebook group around a passion
i think sometimes it's a good it's a
good insight
yeah i am i i there are there are
definitely a lot i mean i am a big i'm a
big sports fan i love music you know so
i do i pay attention to a lot of
creators across
facebook and tik tok and instagram
around you know those those types of
lifestyle communities and what really
gets me excited though is when there's a
crossover between a conversation on a
digital platform and what's happening in
the real world so you know one of the in
addition to what i just talked about i
also really like
i'm very into the foodie space and the
culinary space and and recipes both as a
fan and a you know at home
aspiring cook but also in my job and you
know what i love is when you know we can
people can get together around you know
ideas for how to make their cooking more
interesting or ideas for how to explore
new recipes and talk about it online in
any of the communities but then also go
and actually experience it and you know
i've even had an experience where you
know i've been part of a community
online and then we go and go out to
dinner together and you and you bridge
that world between
um you know what's happening
and then you get out of it and i i love
that and i think the real world really
matters and it matters consumers what
what's the like
raw kind of like tactical
your point of view and this might even
be like challenging for you to answer
but i'm curious to see where you go what
is like the best way for a creator
that's in love with
doritos or
what do i have your blue bottle coffee
or
nike like what's the best way for a
creator who's watching right now because
we have a lot of them yeah to get a
brand deal or work with a big fortune
500 brand
not maybe an emerging brand any tips or
anything you've seen that's worked
yeah i um well i know emily's gonna be
on right and we we definitely and uh
engaged with her in our doritos logo um
and there have been other examples too
where we've we've seen some creators out
there and we've you know done some
partnerships um i would say something
that really breaks through that's fresh
that hasn't been done before um and then
you know that that integrates the brand
i think in a really authentic way you
know i i don't know if anybody saw this
during the earlier in the in the summer
um there's pretty awesome athlete her
name's christina clemens um and she
qualified for the olympics wearing
doritos earrings
um and
it was it was totally sort of came up
out of nowhere but we quickly you know
we actually did a sponsorship deal with
her we created a bag with her face on it
we we sent her gold earrings that she
could wear
because it was just such a beautiful
natural sort of integration with with
the brand so so it's about it's about
cleverly hacking right it's not about
it's not about finding you on linkedin
and spamming you and saying give me a
deal it's more
[Laughter]
actually vader nation could you just
find steve's son
then i just want her to be overwhelmed
and text me later tomorrow and be like
why'd you do this to me
but to your point
like you know it's how do you hack the
attention to them for you guys to almost
have to or be excited to lean in we want
to we want to right we want to we want
to be out there creating with with
creators so for creators
creators who are frustrated that there's
agencies whether vayner whether gallery
media group whether
dba whether all these places out there
are the gatekeepers one of the ways to
do it is if you love a brand
one of the biggest mistakes i think
creators make and i think this is where
you're going is if you love a brand and
want to do something with them well then
just start doing things with the brand
for free because it's going to catch
their attention whereas a lot of
creators and influencers see that as
like doing something for free and not
getting compensated but if you actually
admire or love a brand i was gonna say
do it with the brands you love like have
it be real have it be authentic if a
brand means something to you
play with it and the brand's gonna
notice we're out there looking and
again wanting to nurturing that fandom
and and you can be a big part of it
stacy thank you for being on continued
success thanks gary
next we welcome arlen hamilton arlen is
the founding
founder and managing partner of
backstage capital a venture capital firm
dedicated to minimizing funding
disparities in tech by investing in high
potential founders who are people of
color women
and and or lgbt having raised 20 million
and invested in nearly 200 startup
companies welcome arlen
thank you hey gary hey arlen how are you
i'm doing well how are you it's great to
see you does it do you still pinch
yourself when you think about you know
how much impact that when i hear those
numbers you know forget about like you
know i you you know i'm a fan of yours
and i've known you a long time forget
about all the awesome stuff like i still
get pumped every time i see an
influencer reading your book on
instagram and all that cool stuff and
we're humans we like that but what about
like when you hear something like over
200 businesses being funded because of
what you created does it still kind of
like feel nice
it does and it's it's probably the only
metric that's still
i can just get you going yeah yeah
because it makes sense i know how much
work goes into it and has gone into it
and how many people are involved but
like you can't quantify
someone writing to you and saying hey
you did this two years ago and x y z hat
that's everything yeah all right we
don't have a lot of time and you you put
out so much great content everybody
who's watching you see her handle right
on the screen i couldn't recommend more
you know how much i believe in tenacity
and
just a lot of things arlene captures a
lot of things i believe and it's why
i've been a supporter of front facing
and behind the scenes but
um i want to get i want to get this i
want to get your thoughts on this
because you know obviously you do this
incredible work that i think is
altruistic but then i also think you
have a lot of great strategy
around something this narrow so i'm just
curious where you are in the scheme of
things on what you see for creators and
communities you know we've seen
you know the discords the reddits you
know there's a
the robin hood stuff we've seen
communities really gain a lot of
momentum and then obviously craters is
like the new slang term for influencers
and we've seen that as well
just curious you see so many startups
you're so in the ecosystem
what are your observations for the
state of the union of those two things
in our society
yeah i think maybe i'll be a little
different than a lot of your guests but
not in a bad way
i'm kind of old school i guess because i
don't know if it's my age or if it's
just like my
my predilection for like uh being a
creature of habit but i don't i don't
jump on new things um you know my
brother had to drag me into tick tock to
kind of understand it but i have twitter
and instagram
and i just go
really deep
in those places and so
you know i know how to use them i know
what things will resonate on each
platform you've got the context down
i'm sorry
you've got the context of those
distributions down yeah definitely and
then the context of me right so
i've been in addition to backstage which
has been the last part of the decade of
my life another decade prior to that i
had a blog called your daily lesbian
moment which had 50 000 people from all
over the world who came to this blog
every day to read a little blog post
that i would put up and so i just i
studied it i was definitely broke at the
time you know i didn't have any
resources but i would study
their behavior
and
hey
okay what
what you would read the comments
that was a lot of people forget blog
world you know
when we would post back then the
comments would live on our site
i'd read the comments and then the
comments came alive because sometimes
people would meet their friends there
they would meet um dates there some
people got married after a while like it
was a whole thing and and you know i
would it would take longer than it does
today but eventually three or four years
later somebody would walk up to me and
say something that
you know so i read
you what did you what did you learn
about communities during that time
because it sounds like very similar to
me by the way yeah
library wine library tv
my i lived in the comments on
winelibrarytv.com
you would embed your youtube video on
your wordpress and then have the
comments that i would live in there and
read and i think a lot of my skills were
formed in there it sounds like we have
some similarities there what um what did
you learn
uh
i learned that it's where i uh funny
enough picked up the authenticity how
how much that spreads and how important
that is and how
like valuable it is
right i mean even my shirt right now is
my shirt it says be yourself so that the
people looking for you can find you
i said this maybe three years ago at
south by and it kind of picked up
but it's where i mean this whole past
you know 20 18 20 years that's where
i've picked that up
because no matter what i was going
through
whether if i was in good times or bad
times and both have happened in public
right no matter what i was going through
you had that that instant kind of
connection and if you were honest about
if i was honest about it good and bad
and celebrated and kind of you know
commiserated all of that
somebody in the audience was feeling the
same thing
and they remember that kind of thing and
that's carried out with me
what about you on the consuming side
what kind of creators
tend to
catch your attention
is it in a style of content is it
besides subject matter which would be
obviously incredibly obvious is there
anything you know that stands out for
you in the influencer creator community
these days i like really clever people
who have
you may you know you may notice oh okay
their camera isn't that expensive or
they're using their phone or whatever
but they are just being so
they have such initiative and they're
just being
so clever in how they use the tools at
hand
that and that can mean they have a lot
of equipment they have a lot of things
but whatever it is it it it punches
above the weight of what they have and
so i love being able to notice that and
i love things that are
they teach me something of course if
they make me laugh they're you know you
have my heart but if
something you know like
in a in a really fast way and i can just
like well i didn't think of it like that
before
do you do you go from seeing a tweet or
in your instagram feed because it sounds
like those two places you're more native
to
are is it common for you to see
something you liked it intuitively to
your point whether it is laugh i love
that i agree
or oh that's that's a clever take on
something i've been thinking one way
that club will you find yourself going
down a rabbit hole
and then like oh johnny or susan got my
attention for a second and then 15
minutes later you've like consumed 7 12
15 and now you decide oh was that a
one-off and i only like that one piece
of content or am i about this person no
i go into the vortex hard
i go you know you talk about going deep
into comments and not only that
that's how i
get a lot of the inspiration or i i
connect with people so you know i may
uh chacho on my team on backstage team
he became my chief of staff and and on
the partner track now because i consumed
his content on twitter you know when he
didn't know i was looking at it when he
didn't know that that a tweet that he
did two years prior to the one that he
sent to me
was gonna resonate and say oh this tells
me one more piece of the puzzle another
thing i like to do is on twitter and and
some sometimes on instagram is i like to
look at what people liked that tells me
a lot about them right i agree yeah and
especially if it's someone i'm like okay
do i want them to work with me do i want
them to you know do i want to invest in
them now i have a new company do i want
to hire them for the new company that
sort of thing
i love that what about the um
what about the frameworks around
community how much or how little or
what's a
deep or maybe even a hot take on things
like discord
reddit like the containers of community
any thoughts because again you're
looking at so many startups as well do
we are we seeing an evolution of
community
yes we are i mean so many people have
opinion
uh
but by the way you can stop right there
we can add the whole show yeah thank you
for having me um have opinion of the
facebook's you know the kind of the the
gentleman the establishments yep yeah
and i i'll tell you the reason i don't
go to a lot of places uh not to say that
instagram and twitter are safer but i
just
it's it's difficult sometimes you know
to read some of the comments and some of
the things it's it's it's a tough uh
balance
um so what i think could be what i look
for and what i think is interesting are
two things one is one are companies
startups that are there to help make
those current experiences safer and more
pleasant they don't have to be without
critique they don't have to be without
edge but just simply you feel like
you're not going to be called every
racist name in the book when you walk
down the street and then the other one
is are the ones that are just more niche
that are just like
better that are interesting um that are
maybe being built around
uh you know some of the some of the
things that are coming your way like
i've like for instance i i own a couple
of nfts i'll tell you one of the nfts i
own is garyvee gifting me an nft
so that's my foray into it but then
there's i'm able to look at companies
that are building around
you know the nft community so whereas i
may not be like oh i got to get an nft
tomorrow that's my thing
i'll leave that to chacho because that's
what he wants
um
on my brother
um i look at it oh that's it's really
like your your discord for for me
friends like i read your discord but i
didn't
i you know i was like i don't know how
to get an nfg
i was over there gas what is get
somebody has
why are they farting in this house
everybody's so excited about gas or
upset about it
but i i read what was happening yes
consuming yeah and that and you know and
i saw the all the phases of it including
you know i i studied i was like this is
so predictable because ever there's some
people who are like ah man i don't like
this you know this is a scam and i'm
like
first of all
like i don't know something happened
when you had like a week or something
delay and then in that week the price
that they bought went up and so they got
like they made a fortune made money off
of the first week so i said oh okay
there's something here
and it was the comments that helped me
understand the context
yes what's happening same for me arlen
you're you're a real gem please
everybody get to know this woman
no matter what you do thanks for being
on we'll talk soon thank you thanks
arlen
next up we welcome blake gray he's a
creator a model and an actor
blake came into the creator scene in
2015 and has since become one of the
four front creators on tick tock with
over 10 million followers
he's also partnered up with some pretty
big brands including aloe paxsun mlb
revolve and prada
welcome blake
thank you thank you what's up man how
are you i'm well blake how are you doing
good a little nervous my first ever live
interview so i appreciate you having me
on man you're gonna crush my man so
blake why don't you
um here's a good one you know
you're in such an interesting spot for a
lot of people that are watching you're
super young
you're at the forefront winning on the
platform that's kind of winning the day
10 million plus on on
um on tick tock right even looking at
your you know creator model actor that's
super awesome like like there's a lot of
blessings in that right you didn't get
you didn't do much to be born attractive
right like
what why don't you educate everybody
because you're in it right i i know
enough about you we've interacted in the
past why don't you give everybody
a real view of like what are people that
are perceptionally winning on tick tock
struggling with
what is awesome and what's a struggle
from the perspective of not only you
though you're more than welcome to go
there but you get to interact with a lot
of people like you
and you might be able to give people a
little bit of a view under the hood of
what's working and what's challenging
um yeah so i mean
i uh i started about five years ago and
it kind of just happened by accident i
was just playing baseball doing my thing
at school and um being a creator it
definitely is fun it has its ups and
downs um
you know it's it's hard being
a kid nowadays uh especially having such
a big following i think that's what's
the hardest thing about being a creator
i can't really go to an amusement park
or go to a movie and enjoy it um i feel
like that's one of the
and where are you where are you
in that cycle of your life do you feel
because you're so how old are you i'm
only 20. right so and i love that you
said i'm only like i'm you're only 20
years old so for me as somebody else who
has 10 million followers on tick tock
you know i'm a grown man i'm 45 years
old and
i can't do those things either
but but because i'm at 45
and like not 20 i believe it is easier
for me to just only filter that as
complete gratitude like i'm so flattered
every time there is no other even when
they bother me with even the things that
i'm most protective of i still don't
know how to see that attention
as anything but i can't believe this is
happening yeah
and of course being 20
there's a lot that comes along with that
you know especially going from 15 to 20
going through this process
when you're dating someone when you
weren't like all the things that come
along with it and then everything else
are you
do you think you're taking it for
granted
uh do you think it's cool are you in
that phase where you're like
like do you think sometimes you lose
perspective or are you so grateful but
it's just you can't function like where
are you at with it right now and i'm
sure it's ebbed and flowed
you know i mean
since i've been doing it for so long i
still remember the first time somebody
ever came up to me and it was literally
the most surreal feeling i've ever had
in my life i still just don't understand
why people come up to me it blows my
mind i'm so grateful and blessed um so
yeah i know i'm i don't take it for
granted at all you know uh i wouldn't be
here without all my followers and my
fans but do you but at the same token if
you're on a date or you're hanging with
your boys
is there a struggle there with it or or
is it more of a fear of like everything
you're doing is being watched i think
now it's more well back then it was more
of a struggle because
growing up in houston texas this is so
new especially five years ago a lot of
my friends and family didn't even know
how to act i think i was more worried
about what my
family and friends thought of it rather
than yeah so i mean i was always just so
like wow this is so cool but my friends
and family they were just like what is
going on why do they want it
especially five years ago it's so new um
but yeah no i i definitely
don't take it for granted and now
my family and friends definitely
see what is going on and they're very
happy for me so like how should brands
there's a lot of marketers
on here a lot of cmos a lot of marketers
how
what do brands do wrong with big
influencers like how do they get it
wrong
it's not necessarily that they're doing
anything wrong i think this comes more
than the creative aspect since i'm like
but real quick because i can tell you're
such a sweet dude this will actually
help
you're welcome you just
this
um this will help you like
this will really help them if they hear
it from you so like i sit in the middle
with my company and i'm like guys you
can't tell blake got 10 million
followers because he [ __ ] knows his
audience let like you get to choose if
you're gonna do something with blake but
let him do what he wants to do thank you
yes that's exactly what i was about to
say i love it when brands give me uh you
know the creative and they're like yeah
you know your audience best do do
whatever you think is gonna do great for
the brand and i think that's what i see
does best on my channel when i work with
brands is when they give me the creative
and they say you just completely can do
something that you know they'll like
versus feeding you lines
exactly exactly i think also
i
don't necessarily i'm not gonna work
with somebody that i don't believe in or
take pride in i'm not gonna promote
something that
i don't know anything about or i'm not
happy with um so that's another reason
why it's good to work with brands that
fit with you know my talk to me about
talk to me about collaborations
you know
when you get to this level or on the way
from zero to 10 million
um
how important was it to do other things
with other creators so that you could
get awareness in their community and
they could get awareness from your
community how do you think about
collaborations
uh i think they're great obviously being
in quarantine for the past two years and
covet and everything it hasn't really
been aced it's been very hard to collab
with people but
um
tick tock having the duet and stitch
thing
it's easy to collab with people without
even being with people i'll go and duet
somebody and it's pretty much me
essentially collabing with them i don't
have to go meet up with them or anything
um but five years ago when i was first
getting started collabing was so
important i would have to
fly somewhere yeah fly somewhere you
know i even like i'm not sure i'm not
sure 16 year old you going to your
parents being like yo i got to fly to la
to do this dance with ricky was going to
be the easiest thing to sell right yeah
no not at all um
even like this right now we're collabing
you know this is 100 right this is great
like what uh
what's your biggest ambition right now
obviously that will change at 25 and 30
and 35 and 40. but right now as a 20
year old dude with this momentum and
these blessings
do you want to
i see actor like do you want to
be a superhero in a movie do you want to
like you want to become a big actor is
the modeling thing more fun like is that
like you know a thing that just is epic
is it more on the creator side like if i
said next three four years what would be
one epic thing you'd like to accomplish
what stands out you know being a
superhero would be sick um
which superhero would if if i said good
news i'm a genie from the future you're
gonna be one of the actors that gets to
be a superhero in a superhero movie
which one would you want to be that's
that's right now
yeah
okay iron man hands down
yeah you can't go wrong with iron man or
captain america those two
are my favorite yeah you think you can
get your muscles up for captain america
i know i need to bulk up a little bit
uh
like any any final thought any emerging
platform
or app that people might not know about
anything brewing in the in the kids land
that people should keep an eye out maybe
get a first read
you never know i mean tick tock came out
of nowhere man you know as a creator i'm
always looking for the next big app
that's going to blow up like tick tock
yep but nothing right now of choice no i
haven't seen anything right now now
like thanks for being on the show
brother thank you so much man appreciate
it that was awesome thank you blake and
thank you gary
thank you next time
have a great day you too
next up we welcome ryan harwood he's the
ceo of gallery media group
thanks for joining ryan
guess what
today we are going to be chatting with
christina
better known as tinx the breakthrough
star behind the at its meetings accounts
tinks is an la based st sanford grad
otherwise known as tick tock's big
sister in less than a year she's gained
over a million followers on her
platforms and has partnered with great
brands including chipotle skims bmw mini
cooper and the real real and more
welcome ryan and
hi
hey tanks welcome welcome
thanks for joining me
thanks for having me
absolutely so
first off you're you're on fire so i
just got to say that right now and
before we start can we just talk for a
second about gwyneth
um you know
that was
yeah that was honestly the coolest
collab ever i i still can't believe it's
real um she's been an idol of mine
forever and
i mean let's face it she's the og rich
mom so it's pretty cool that she
um collabed with me in that way she's so
funny so smart um so warm so it was a
really a dream come true and a dream
come true to see her hold minnie mike so
it was it's a good day
i love it for the audience if you don't
know what i'm talking about go to tynx's
instagram account check out her most
recent post it is awesome how that
collab came together so just wanted to
get that out of the way because it's so
recent
but um
you know i love origin stories tell me
in a nutshell how you became a creator
was it purposeful or was it by accident
a little bit of both honestly before i
was doing um before i was a creator i
was a writer and a consultant and i
always thought of myself as kind of a
behind the scenes uh creative you know
never never wanted to be in front of the
camera and then quarantine hit and i was
like i have literally nothing to lose
and i'm enjoying
consuming tick-tock content so much i
might as well give it a go myself and as
soon as i made my first video i realized
this is what i was supposed to do
so in a way all of my work before this
has prepared me for it but um how it
happened was kind of a happy accident
makes sense
you know we have a lot of brand
marketers and chief marketing officers
on the call and you know they're they're
creating their own organic presence on
these platforms
what are some tips that you can give
brands that are also trying to nurture a
community the way that you've nurtured
your own community and built your own
audience
i think finding true fans like i think
finding that whoever is championing your
brand naturally um is so important and
really fostering relationships with
those people because every brand has
super fans um and i think that they're
kind of the backbone of the fandom and
they are really the ones who start the
little movements and who make the
organic content so finding finding out
who those people are and and and forming
meaningful relationships with them is is
so important
how do you think of when you're creating
content for instagram versus tick tock
do you think differently or is it
similar how do you think about that you
know it is it is a slightly different
audience um i think that they
respond to slightly different things um
i think my audience on instagram for me
personally is a little bit older and on
tick tock excuse a little bit younger
and
the the type of content i think we're
just trained to view the two we've been
trained to view them differently like on
tick tock it's all about the hook right
so when i'm thinking about tick tock i
think in the first three seconds am i
grasping their attention whereas on
instagram i know that those those uh
followers are a little bit more engaged
a little bit more patient you know they
have the they'll watch something the
whole way through
um so it is different i think that's
just down to the nature of both of the
apps and the way that people digest and
consume the content on each
yep
and and when you know you you get an
incredible amount of engagement on your
on your
posts which is just awesome it means
that you really truly have a
cult-like following so to say but how do
you determine how any of those comments
you're actually going to respond to and
engage with on each of the platforms
like at what point do you have to be
like i can't you know
it's it's a lot to keep up with i think
um i think where i'm most active is
actually my dms because i give a lot of
advice and a lot of especially women
write into me and that's where i really
try to
spend at least 30 minutes or an hour a
day just going through my dms and
responding to them because you know it
takes a lot to write me and if you're
reaching out and you and you need help
or advice like i take my responsibility
and my platform very seriously so
that's where i spend the majority of my
time the tick tock comment section it's
it can be a little wild in there it can
get really crazy so i i tend to cut
myself off you know usually i'll i'll
just scan the comments and just see the
general um consensus on my post but you
know i i always say this to my followers
like that's ego that's ultimately when
you're reading the comments like that's
your ego looking for a stroke but
ultimately you end up sometimes getting
hit so you've got to cut yourself off
and just just do a scan here and there
like take the pulse of of your followers
and uh and move on because
it can get a little it can get a little
wild
dicey i feel you
have you ever had an instance where your
audience just fully pushed back on a
piece of content that you did
i you know yeah i mean sure i've had
flops and i've i've taken missteps but i
think for me i i'm always so honest with
my followers and i'm i'm coming to this
creator role so late in life that i and
i'm so new to it that i i tell them like
guys i'm gonna make mistakes i'm going
to make missteps but i want you to know
that i'm super self-aware and i'm happy
to course correct and also i'm it's
it's good for me to fail in public
because then i can say i'm sorry or i
can you know explain what went wrong to
them and i feel like i'm kind of growing
with them and i think that the age of
like the perfect creator or the perfect
influencer is over and what people
respond to now is humility humility and
and personal growth and um and someone
who's willing to change and to be to be
influenced themselves so
um yeah i've definitely had flops i've
definitely screwed up before and i'm
sure i will again but i it's you know
it's not a a zero-sum game it's it's
it's a an evolving process
yeah
you know i think one thing that brands
could really take away from
the way creators do things is you guys
collaborate a lot with other humans with
other influencers and i don't think
brands collab with other brands enough
right obviously they do pay partnerships
with influencers but i think they can
collab together so i'm curious from your
perspective
how does collaborating with other
creators contribute to your creative
process how do you think about that i
learn so much from my from other
creators like i lean on my creator
friends more than anybody else now um
and i think it's just it's it's such an
incredible
uh way to to push yourself and to go
outside of your comfort zone and to
learn how other creators do things even
logistically just like collabing with
someone and seeing how they film or
seeing their process and and how they
edit it's it's it's so incredible and i
think you're right i think brands should
collab more i think that audiences
really love
when they feel like worlds are colliding
because they're on the other side of the
screen right and they're watching us and
the response that i get when i collab
with other people it's just like it's
crazy and like you see it on tv
sometimes when you know different shows
will kind of have a world crossover
people love that and that's the way that
i think about the content too like i'm a
character to them and so if i can take
bring another character from tic toc
into my content or vice versa it's just
it's thrilling and it's exciting and
it's it's a win-win all around win for
me when for the other creator win for
the audience because it's interesting so
um yeah i think more brand collabs would
be really fun people get a kick out of
that
is there one creator out there that you
would love to collab with
well now that i've collabed with gwyneth
i mean that was that's that's me done
for a little bit um but you know there's
there's so many people that i that i
want to collab with so many incredible
creators that i'm just i'm so lucky to
know and that are so cool and um
i i can't wait to meet more of them
they're just they're the most
interesting exciting people and um and
i'm lucky to be a part of the community
awesome you know to that point on that
question
gallery media group the company that i
run helped tinder
make the diplo date happen
and we're very happy and proud of that
so i'm asking you as someone that's deep
in the community and in dating advice
who's the next date we should try to
make happen within the tick tock
community
oh well you should probably set me up
with harry styles next
oh my god
is that is that too much i just i i
think that i am a good person to go on a
date with so at least you know it's fun
and entertaining and and i can edit
videos well so i don't know
i love it quick speed round of questions
to get to know you salty or sweet sweet
disney plus or netflix netflix
summer or winter winter
80s or 90s music
90s
almond milk or oat milk
coconut milk
nba or nfl
uh nba
last one friends or seinfeld seinfeld
tanks thank you so much for joining us
we appreciate you having me
so much fun bye guys awesome thanks tinx
all right next up ryan you have a gaggle
coming on
we're going to be chatting with nate
wyatt
ozra mian
aisha meon
uh nate is a multi-hyphenate content
creator
actor and recording artist nate has
amassed a following over 8 million loyal
fans across numerous social media
platforms
and at 20 years old the mian
twins became overnight sensations on
youtube and tick tock less than a year
ago now boasting over 8 million
followers originally from new york the
pakistani albanian duo started their
youtube channel when they were 13
posting beauty tutorials twin challenges
and vlogs welcome everyone hi thank you
for having us yeah thank you
absolutely thanks for coming on guys
we're excited to have you
um so
triple triple threat mate creator actor
and recording artist i love it you're a
swiss army knife yeah
tell me
were you a creator before you became an
actor recording artist or was it vice
versa how did that all evolve
yeah so um i've been singing since i was
a kid i got into acting uh right after
high school when i was 19 years old and
i didn't have a follow-up so i'm from
ohio and i moved out to la right after
high school um not having a social
platform kind of coming out and was
gonna do the whole you know acting route
get a job um what not and you know just
pay my dues and you know get it like
everyone else has like in the you know
acting community and whatnot um and then
i got out here and
i was on social media because it was a
way it was my form of like entertainment
at the time because like i control
social media you know i can't control
when i have an audition when i book
something et cetera so um
you know i was also just on social media
when i got out here for fun and it kind
of took
like a path of its own i like i tell
people i think social media uh you know
it's preparation but it's also a little
bit of luck so it kind of just happens
um
and yeah that's kind of how i got it to
it so i was i yeah i was an actor and a
musician uh before i was a creator yeah
makes sense awesome um aisha i'm gonna
ask you a question here so
how do you think about when you're
creating content how do you
authentically
engage your audience in a way that is
like truly you how do you think about
that um i just think
like really important to make sure
you're staying true to yourself
especially when it comes to making
content it could be very easy to start
wanting to like
make content specifically just because
you know that let's say it's performing
well for someone else or this or that
and i think that it's very easy to
notice when your fan base can be a
change in the way that you're acting
based on you know if you see a technique
working for another creator and that
like starts to change the way that you
uh make your content um so i think it's
just really important to like stay true
to what you began with and you know just
staying true like your true intention on
social media because it's very easy to
see that from like a fan perspective
like see a change in the creator or the
way that they're creating their content
or the way that they interact with the
fans so just kind of staying true to
yourself and it's easy to get lost in it
but
always bringing that back down that's
right
i love it and azra how is the how has
the rise of tick tock
impacted your career trajectory and
goals as a content creator oh my gosh um
i mean it's changed our life so much
like just two years ago we were living
in new york going to college for like
marketing and business and now we're
living in la and doing content as our
full-time job so i would say that
definitely like
you know
doing social media and doing what we do
now it
it i feel like it's still not taken as
seriously as it should be some people
still look at it look at it as just them
making content and it's not a real job
but from our end they don't like people
like fans don't see the work that goes
behind it and the meetings that we're in
the brands we're talking to and that one
tick tock can sometimes take us a few
weeks to film because we're going back
and forth with the brand so i just
wanted to be taken more seriously and
it's just definitely changed i feel like
the outlook um
has changed a little bit and i think
people are starting to see that um but i
mean just doing tic tac in general has
changed our life so much like just two
years ago even a year ago like we just
moved out here we were so fresh so it's
just crazy to see how
social media can now be
such a you know it's a big part of
everyone's life but can be such a big
job especially for us because we're only
20 years old like and our life has
changed so much from it so i mean
big talk and social media in general has
just changed the game for sure yeah
hey nate you know we have a lot of
senior marketers watching the show chief
marketing officers brand managers the
people that are dying to collaborate
with all three of you yeah we're always
trying to educate them and and tell them
how to approach you guys in the way
that's going to allow them to unlock
the greatest value for their brand but
also
allow you to really be a creator so i'm
curious from your perspective
how do you prefer brands to engage you
meaning like process wise do you prefer
them
to kind of lead the creative direction a
little bit or do you prefer
to
have explicit direction like do this
like how should they approach you to get
the most out of you and your audience
yeah so i think with a brand um
how to approach us is they can have some
direction a little bit but also let us
like
um chime in on that and give our
creative perspective on what we think
will work because obviously like we know
exactly what's going to work with our
audience um so i wouldn't say just give
us all the creative freedom i would say
give us like little points that they
want us to hit
but then give us also some creative uh
freedom to like hit those um in a way
that'll
help our like in a way that'll work with
our audience because we know what so
yeah yeah i mean what i like to always
say is is let them tell the story the
way they tell stories all the time and
let the br let them make the brand the
hero of the story but stop trying to
force the brand in the first two seconds
and make it so obvious that it's an ad
like tell the story and then let them
figure out how to make the brand the
hero and that story is that a good way
to think about it 100 yeah
awesome and
you know for all three of you do you
guys have like a high-performing brand
partnership in mind that maybe you could
tell us like why you thought it was
successful like why it actually worked
um i would go first i would quickly say
um i just think in general we do post a
lot of lifestyle slash beauty content so
a lot of people that do watch us are
looking at that so when we work with
let's say make a brand specifically we
notice that our audience tends to engage
with it a lot because they already
follow us because of our makeup content
or lifestyle content so working with the
brand that we usually uh kind of revolve
our content around tends to perform
super well whereas like if we were to
work with let's say a video game app or
anything that's really outside of our
bubble might not be perceived as well so
just anything that we can generally base
our content around
yeah i mean i would say i mean i did a
giorgio armani uh
uh cologne collab and when you think of
that you wouldn't think when you think
of a collab or like a commercial with a
clone company you wouldn't think like
really funny or comedy um but i i did
that i put my own twist on it and i made
kind of like a funny skit with the
collab and it got almost like a million
likes and it got millions of views and i
it got way more than if i just made like
a a basic like cologne
like commercial type deal you know what
i mean um i made it funny it made it i
showed personality and it did
way better than
you know i like i thought i would yeah i
love that so we gallery media group was
the one that did that with you guys and
i agree with you it's actually one that
we go to the well and use as an example
a bunch of you guys that were in that
did an incredible job of doing just that
telling a story and then making the
product included in this story as
opposed to making a straight ad so i
agree with you that was a great one
um what do you guys think will be needed
in the future
to keep audiences engaged as the creator
ecosystem just continues to grow at such
a rapid rate do you think that there's
going to be anything that's needed there
um well i think when it comes to like um
social media in general it's always
changing and trends are always changing
and i feel like as you know on the
creative end it's so important for us to
keep up with trends and you know what
people are still engaging with because
like apps die out you know super quick
and trends change and even like really
good like a youtuber for example or even
a tick talker you know there could be
something that's working for them at a
time but then
let's say a year from now that you know
their style i guess you can say isn't
what's working and you know if they
continue with that they're going to
slowly like i don't want to say but like
fall off but that's when you kind of
have to like you know take a little
change in what you're doing and you know
try something new and i think it's
always so important especially for us
like on our end and for the brand's end
to really track these trends and track
what's changing so we can you know
follow it and still stay relevant if
that makes sense
makes complete sense
well guys thank you so very much for
joining us i know this went too quick i
have so many more questions for you but
you are awesome and hope you get to uh
meet in person soon yes so much thanks
everybody
next we welcome gabby fenton thank you
ryan
next we welcome gabby fenton
she just joined us as the head of vayner
lattam
and we like to call her la reina
the queen
because she's amazing amazing
thank you
gabby is going to be chatting with the
wonderful kim farrell from tick tock
she's the director of marketing in latin
america
just a couple words on kim
uh kim has over 2 10 years of experience
in consumer marketing having worked most
of her career for google in both the
united states and sao paulo brazil
and she's led a lot of exciting
campaigns for events like the world cup
and the olympics
and interestingly her life motto is
actually a quote from one of the guests
on our show today um and actually her
favorite tick tock creator tinks you're
not too old and it's not too late
welcome gabby and kim
thank you for having me and yes i was so
excited to see tinks here i am like a
huge fan girl i'm a tank stand forever
for life so that was an amazing question
i feel like i've i've met her in some
way now so i'm very excited about it
from the backstage
exactly and of course she can say that
because she's 20 something right it's
never too late and you're never too old
of course if you're 20 thanks come on
please
hello kim welcome and thank you so much
for doing this because if you didn't say
yes i would have never said yes to being
on the marketing for the now andreas
that i would only do with you
i'm here so thank you so very much kim
and uh nissan you have the coolest
job in the planet
i really feel like i knew i think um
i think we're at this moment of you know
we're here to talk about creators and
community and i think there's really no
better place than than at tick tock uh
and and the moment that we're living
kind of you know as a brand and as a as
a society uh in terms of you know
content creation so it's amazing and
you're my client so that makes me the
second the second coolest person in the
world right
yes i'm your your first client uh in
vladim and i'm you're my first client in
laram how cool can i be that i have like
my first client in latin america opening
the operation is tick tock so i'm the
coolest person in the world
kim uh let's let's start this
conversation i have a question for you
from the frontline said tiktok that it's
like that if we're talking about
creators and communities like there's no
better place to talk about that so what
changes have you seen during the past
year uh like in terms of what truly
defines
engaging content like for today's
consumer
what changes
i think i think what we're really seeing
is it really is all about the the
authentic content the the
unrehearsed the unfiltered the real i
think you know kinks mentioned the age
of perfect creators and i think what
we've really seen is um you know
creators today that are really you know
blowing up and having success are real
people uh you know people want to see
that authenticity they want to kind of
see the spontaneity we see so many
you know some of the most engaging
content is filmed you know when someone
is parked in their car not driving but
you know parked in their car and they
have you know this spontaneous moment
and they film it you know and they film
a tick tock or they're wearing a
sweatshirt you know lying on their couch
or you know they're completely you know
no makeup and and really real and so i
think that um that's what we're really
seeing is engaging real authentic
content and and that's where we're
getting such intense communities as well
because you're connecting over you know
you're connecting over real things
real life
you think that's that's that's a trend
like going back to the human beings
behind off like the marketing because
i've been in this business for almost 30
years and we we didn't used to do that
like we we did advertising and
everything was so staged when i see my
my work from like
10 years ago not that much it's like so
staged and so fake and so not real
i know and i think i mean i think it's
funny that um i think uh the the twins
were just talking about how they would
love for you know creators to have more
more respect and i think we as marketers
need to recognize they're the best
marketers out there and they're
really making our processes and our
lives easier because they know how to
engage with their audience they make
content in a lot of ways faster or more
efficiently or more cost effectively
than when we are doing these you know
major productions and spending months
developing something you know they can
really you know
you know in on a moment's notice create
some of the most best content that
really creates that genuine connection
for your brand so um yeah i think you
know we we i think maybe a few years ago
it was um maybe slightly more looked
down upon to be an influencer or a
creator uh you know or say you were
doing a public post or an or an ad and i
think um you know today we're really
embracing and really respecting that
they really are uh the best marketers
and the best you know the best way to
get get your message out there uh you
know for a lot of us they are the best
marketers which leads me to another
question i have for you what advice
would you tell that like would you give
the creators in terms of of that like
being proud of of getting paid to do
that
yeah i think like i i mean i think kinks
who is here is a is a great example she
is so honest with her
audience about you know how she works
with brands and you know what she's paid
for and i think that um you know part of
being real creators and being more
authentic creators is that their
communities are engaging with them as as
real people and as full people you know
not necessarily just around one type of
content you know so you can maybe uh be
across many verticals and it becomes
more about who you are as a person and
who you stand for and if you think about
it that makes you more like maybe a
friend to these people and when your
friend does something you root for your
friend you encourage your friend you're
like yes girl like go get that
exactly so i think what we're seeing is
that people are much more accepting of
knowing that there's you know a business
involved and that these are these this
is a profession um and people are making
you know there is money being exchanged
for it but if it's done in a really
genuine way and i think a lot of the
creators have talked about you know
engaging with the brand in a way that
they have creative freedom um and you
know they take a lot of responsibility
for their audiences and so there's a lot
of responsibility on the creator i think
as well and so uh when you balance when
you kind of bring all of that together
um i think that that's uh really really
the advice i would say is just you know
embrace the authenticity of your
audience and who you are as the person
and and don't shy away from that you
know fly your creator flag you know be
that embrace it you know i think that's
that's what i really love to see
what i love about what i'm seeing is
that brands and people are
are embracing that they're like like
like receiving it like
happily because what we did previously
in the past years is people used our job
to go and make a sandwich or go to pee
that's what we did when when the ads
came right you make language are you pee
but now it's it's so authentic and so
real that it's part of your daily
conversation so you don't need to go and
pee in that time
and i think i think and and i mean i
think we're we're seeing how how our
our tactics as brands and as marketers
are changing because instead of
necessarily thinking about you know um
the exact micro moments on the journey
and necessarily always focusing on those
those ad targeting you know we start
talking about communities and engaging
in the community and this
like the sub community you know we talk
people joke about sub talks and you know
really really niche communities and you
can find that if you engage with them it
doesn't really matter the necessarily
the format or the time or the place it's
it's a it's really is about the content
and about the you know the creators
you're working with and and the way that
it you know kind of the the way that it
reaches them um so i think it's it's
really changing kind of the way that we
approach how we reach our audience and i
think it's funny that we talk about
audiences but really our audience is our
communities today of course and of
course you're gonna serve me what i
wanna be served so so that makes a
difference as well right
so i have a very difficult question for
you because it's difficult for me so i
hear a lot of people saying oh
when the older generation comes into a
platform like myself okay so whenever
the older generation comes into a
platform they say like oh you can kiss
that platform goodbye right what would
you say to those people because because
because older generations are coming
into your platform
yes
i totally disagree um and i think
especially like with you know especially
with tick tock um you know it really is
such a personalized experience that you
see the content that you engage with
right and and um so i think it's much
more about the
the true connections that you find with
the content it's what you're going to
see and so there really is room for
everyone uh you're for you is going to
be like what you want to see and it's
it's about the communities that you want
to engage with and the creators that you
want to engage with sure definitely
we'll mix things in there but you know
it it it'll figure you out um you know
in a way that will kind of uh you know
really allow you to have the experience
that you want within the app and i think
also i mean i personally um
follow
many creators across many different age
groups um and i think that's really the
beauty of it because it's more of a like
state of mind and a and a way of
self-expression than it is about you
know exactly how old and i think the
last thing is you know it really is a
platform that starts with content and so
it's not really uh based on you know um
maybe in other platforms where it's all
about yours your social network you know
people that you know i think we really
lead with with the content and so that
can come from anyone and and from
anywhere so so yeah i'm i i'm excited
for for everyone to to come on board and
and you know find find their place i'm
super excited i have one last question
for you kim uh so in latin america the
the brands that are not like in tick
tock not now what would you tell them
because there's a lot of brands that are
not in tick tock and i i like spent most
of my day
trying to engage them what would you
tell
them i mean you're missing out right
like
i think that's the easiest thing is
honestly you're just missing out i think
we are seeing culture forum on our
platform every day we are seeing you
know some of the most engaged
communities communities that you didn't
really know exist or you couldn't have
found in other places and i think we're
really democratizing um you know the way
that content is made and the way that
people collaborate with each other and
why wouldn't you want to be a part of
that you know it really is um you know
we i think we all know today that that
uh marketing is not a one-way
conversation and so why wouldn't you
want to be in a place where you can your
your audience your community your fans
can be your voice you can talk directly
with them you can stitch you can duet
they can take your audio they can use
your filter and so i just think it's
such a playground for for creativity and
for real connection for brands that um
yeah i'd say you should you should come
join the party
and it's fun i mean it's it's it's the
most fun you can have right
thank you so much for being here kim
thank you so much i love that come join
the party
thank you ladies
thank you
we're so excited to have a bonus guest
today
it's none other than emily zuge she's a
tick-tock creator extraordinaire
oh my goodness this is just quite the
moment in fact my daughter just called
me on the phone and said i can't believe
you're having her on the show
so one thing emily i have to confess i
almost had a heart attack when i was
watching the ellen show and you were on
it sharing all of these logos that you
had redesigned
i come from interbrand which is one of
the preeminent branding uh you know
design shops in the world and to see how
you had changed up these logos
it was just beyond it blew my mind and
i'm wondering maybe what we could do is
have you tell a little bit about your
story where you began and then maybe you
can share a couple of them uh just so
that anyone that hasn't had a chance to
take a peek i know you've had over a
hundred million views
but there may be a guest or two on our
show that isn't familiar with your work
so we'd love to hear a little bit about
the the origin story and then maybe we
can dive into some of the work
five five five
your headphones might be turning you
into a robot
is my guess
we're hearing some reverb so maybe just
try
pulling those out and uh we'll see if we
can work on the tech for a second
it i think it's it's still happening all
right we're gonna try to see if we can't
fix that tech
and we're gonna take a peek at some of
the logos that she's created as we heard
from frito-lay earlier um they
she had a chance to redesign the doritos
logo um and take a look at this so i
think the interesting thing will be to
hear not only
how she came up with some of these
designs
but also what was the reaction from
from some of the different brands
themselves and the companies did they
embrace it did they push back
um you know what was that what did we
hear from listening to culture and all
those kind of things
so i'm hoping we can hear back from
emily
in just a
oh second still it's still going one
other fun fact about emily is she comes
from grand rapids michigan which happens
to be where i was born so that was
another thing that uh that made that
made me really excited to bring her on
as a guest
and perhaps if if we don't get her um
here let's try it third time's a charm
oh my gosh
you know what i moved to a different
room sorry this is so casual let me
close my window
that's i love it i love it that's the
way we are on this show it's all real
time we're just having fun here we get
to see we get a tour of your of your
house yeah of course as well so
fantastic
[Laughter]
so tell us a little bit more about why
how did you come up with this idea in
the first place uh you know share some
of those stories and then maybe we can
take a peek at some some of the examples
yeah absolutely
um
so i think i kind of have to go back to
the beginning of my of my content um
i dove into
satire content satirical videos i don't
know what you want to call it um in
april just from experimenting and kind
of like goofing around and trying to
quite frankly like mess with people
in the nicest way possible um
but what i found was like these these
videos had like really great engagement
um that i would post where i would
almost play this like dumb blonde
character and
people had a lot to say about it so um i
thought hey this you know any press is
good press at this point in my career
because i'm a very small creator so um
and i'm okay with it i like it i think
it's funny um so i started to create
these
reaction videos to the comments i would
be seeing and people would call me out
left and right and they would think i
was serious um this created a fun like
little bond with my audience though
because um
i think they like to be a part of the
joke and i think it was kind of like
silly to see people who like really just
it kind of went right over their heads
like some of them were just so
ridiculous like i have a video of myself
peeling a banana with a potato peeler
and people think it's real
so
um
you know that kind of like developed
into what it was and i i just felt
really comfortable with my audience we
always just had tons of fun with like
new videos i'd post and they would
always say oh i can't wait to see the
comment reading videos
um so i put out a logo video thinking i
would create another comment reading
video just to kind of see what people
would say about it um
did you take any acting lessons because
you're obviously you're you know you're
this very kind sweet person
uh and yet the you know the the the
image that you project in a lot of your
work is you know is a whole different
character right
it is yes um thank you so much that's so
sweet um i tried to so i actually did go
to school for for animation um i've
always been like super fascinated with
just the concept of entertaining people
um
so tick-tock kind of gave me a place
where like i never would have thought
i'd be known for like comedy or anything
like that but it really gave me a
platform to sort of like experiment and
like bring that side out of me and feel
comfortable with my audience to try
something new
um
so yeah no like acting experience i just
try to be that person in like critiques
that i would experience who thought that
they were like
the best at everything and everybody
like would look at like each other and
know that this person needs to calm down
using all that fancy language and
all that yeah kind of salesmanship right
yes so this is uh this is my beautiful
work i hope you you uh enjoy it this is
for doritos um we heard a little bit
about it earlier in the show and they
were yeah it sounded like frito-lay tell
talk about the reaction because it
sounded like they kind of dug it even
though you would think you know they
might push back yeah they commented on
the first logo video we're like we need
we need a logo so i was like okay
doritos boom everybody knows doritos
everybody loves doritos so um i try to
choose brands that like generally
everybody can identify and recognize so
um they're hilarious they put it as
their profile picture they're so fun to
comment back with
that's great
oh yes the jonas brothers
originally had
kevin jonas like dm me and joe jonas
commented on one of the logo videos
which was insane
um and they're like the jonas brothers
they we we need a new logo so i was like
okay i got you um and this is like
definitely one of my favorite ones
it's so good
so good
mcdonald's
special place in my heart
what was your reaction from like
mcdonald's lovers did you get did you
get any pushback or was it or people
just enjoying it because it's you know
it's fun and it's funny
um i think people like actually thought
it was funny because well on facebook
i'd seen
um they changed their profile picture to
it and then on linkedin someone had
posted something that was the most liked
mcdonald's profile picture ever which
was hilarious so i think people just
like to see uh you know these big brands
playing into it and just kind of having
fun and you know it's it's not that
serious you know
yeah like the the ellen degeneres i
heard the big uh gift basket that she
awarded you at the end yes with the with
the new logo loved it loved it oh my
gosh that was fantastic oh we have the
nipple now with the present of the
football in america peyton manning um
this was also a fun one
the nfl was so fun to work with too
they'd they'd like made a video
critiquing my profile picture and
remaking the
photoshopping me an entirely new profile
picture so just the back and forth with
these companies has been like so fun and
so unexpected but like
you know it's just been great did you
ever think it was gonna take off to this
extent when you started off i did not i
to be completely honest i
i thought that maybe a small group of
designers would see my video and kind of
crucify me um for lack of better
term um because that's that's like what
i did you know just kind of like put
content out and be like a little troll
and have fun um but i did not expect
this to reach brands to to
to like make a few headlines which was
really cool i definitely did not foresee
that um so that was yeah a very very
cool surprise for me
oh yes and oh and look at this oh my
gosh
oh i you know what we have to bring
georgia and summer you have to come on
screen for just a second i think emily's
just redesigned our marketing for the
now logo what do you think we were
actually talking about maybe we needed
something that was like a little has a
little bit more fire to it all right
it's all there it's got everything
oh i love it i love it well thank you
for taking the time to do that emily we
know how busy you are with all these
there's a lot more logos out there that
you're i'm sure that you're you're
redesigning so the fact that you took
time for ours means means a lot one
question i wanted to hear a little bit
more why did you decide um to kind of
embrace tick-tock as your as your
platform
yeah i think that's a great question um
so all throughout college like i said i
was just obsessed with like i just wanna
i wanna make animations i wanna draw
things i want to make videos like i just
want to entertain people and um i tried
youtube in college i literally uploaded
once a week for an entire year and at
the end of that year i i think i had 350
subscribers so
after all that work it it was just you
know to me it was like oh 350 but to
come over to tick tock and um
see the overnight success that people
were having was mind-blowing to me so
you know i had to ask myself like why
can't that be me why why can't i make
this work on this app you know why not
start fresh so um there's opportunities
right now gary's always saying that you
gotta you know let's embrace it now
because it could change but uh yeah the
opportunity today is enormous absolutely
yeah it's just such a great marketing
tool um i i think i've just grown as a
person too being on the app and learning
a lot and i don't know i just love it
i'm having such a great time that's
amazing and what about what other
aspirations do you have i'm sure this
isn't the only thing you're doing tell
us a little bit more about kind of your
everyday and you know what you're what
you're dreaming about for the future
yeah
i hope to create uh content keep going
uh down this road with with comedy i'm
really enjoying it um
i
am actually a pet portrait artist i do
that full-time and well tick-tock's now
kind of becoming my other full-time job
um
but yeah so so you know i love um doing
my pet portraits it's a great way for me
to connect with my audience um and just
have some more personal relationships
there um
but yeah i don't know i just hope to to
develop this further and kind of see
some longevity in it versus you know
being a trend and uh i don't know i want
to transition other platforms kind of
connect with my audience a little bit
more and they know the the deadpan
delivery version of myself but i hope
that you know there are people out there
who also want to know me uh emily
the person behind the you know the bad
logos well let's do whatever we can do
to support emily whether it's the pet
portraits or being a part of her
community thank you so much for joining
us today emily it's been such a joy and
uh we love our new logo so oh
absolutely thank you guys so much for
having me sorry about the audio issues
oh no it makes it all fun
that's yet another persona right for
emily all right thanks everybody for
joining the show today
uh we're excited to have you guys join
us in november on november 11th for our
next show and until then i hope you guys
are off and um often creating we'll see
you soon